تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث قالت
هيئه الاركان الاركاني الاوكرانيه ان قصف
روسيا قال مناطق السكنيه في كوبيانسك في
مقاطعه خارجيف وايضا لمن في مقاطعه دوناتس
واضافت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
تصدق بهامات روسيه في مقاطعه لوغانسكو
ومحاوره في مدن سوريدار
ومحمود ومدن اخرى في مقاطعه دوناتسكي
وكانت وحدات الاستطلاع الاوكرانيه قالت
لها لقتلها من ميليشيات الروسيه في مدينه
سوليدار شرقا البلاد
كمان على هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
قواتها الجويه شنت خلال الساعات الماضيه
16 غارتا على مواقع تمركز القوات روسيه
ومنظوماتها الصاروخيه داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه واضافت الهيئه ان قوه مدفعيه
الاوكرانيه دمرت مستودعات الاسلحه
والاعتاد واسقطت مروحيه روسيه وتابعت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه الى القوات الروسيه
شلت في المقابل انسي اكثر من 20 غاره جويه
على الاحياء السكنيه في خرسون جنوب البلاد